[Music]
hey guys Helen again so I know we've
talked about Rick and Morty a lot but
while Jarrod's been lamenting the lack
of meaning in our [ __ ] universe I
thought it was time to give science a
chance to shine light on everyone's
favorite negligent grandpa and his uh
talented career savvy son-in-law when do
we need food when we're hungry
specifically I wanted to see what
psychology had to say about a problem
we've all been asking ourselves is Rick
destined to be miserable because of his
intelligence and if so is it better to
be a Jerry if you ask nineteenth-century
author Fyodor Dostoevsky he would
probably say no as he famously puts it
in the idiot it is better to be unhappy
and know the worst than to be happy in a
fool's paradise
Dostoyevsky statement seems quite apt in
describing the dynamic between Jerry and
Rick Crick's despondency is driven by
his knowledge that nothing matters while
a fool's paradise might as well just be
Jerry breathe the Shyamalan simulation
yes you just sold the apples campaign
who just sold the apples campaign may
Pluto or the Titanic look it's the line
for the bow so it's best whiskey right
we'll break it down in this wisecrack
edition on the psychology of Rick and
Morty can being smart make you miserable
and as always spoilers ahead for being
the smartest man in the universe
Rick surprisingly relatable as co
creator Dan Harmon puts it when you're
standing in line at that banks sometimes
you always feel like none of these
people understand what a hurry I'm in
how much crap I have to do today what
I'm up against
we've all been tricked and as much as it
sucks to admit a lot of us can also
probably identify with his self-loathing
and self-destructive behavior I don't
know Morty maybe I hate myself maybe I
think I deserved to die I don't know
Rick is practically omnipotent with the
power to invent transform and destroy
his way into getting whatever he wants
yet despite all that power he's
miserable on the other hand there's
Jerry who's a little bit dumb and a lot
a bit discombobulated
Jerry operates best when he doesn't have
to think too much because when he does
he generally makes things worse
but even when he's down in the deepest
of dumps he doesn't seem to stop
to the same degree that Rick does Jerry
may not have street smarts or be able to
hold down a job but he's also not
hitting the bottle or questioning his
place in the universe and his barber
happiness seems low don't move hmm so is
it better to be a Rick or a Jerry first
let's look at Rick his inner turmoil
leaks out in some subtle and not so
subtle ways like his famous catchphrase
Morty do you know what Wubba lubba dub
dub means that's just stupid nonsense
catchphrase it's not nonsense at all in
my peoples tongue it means I am in great
pain please help me and obviously that
way to real suicide attempt in season
two but is it because he's smart the
stereotype of the torture genius is so
deeply woven into pop culture that we
should wonder whether its overblown
Hollywood [ __ ] the roster of famous
folks from history who've suffered from
crushing depression and the attention
given to the brilliance madness linked
by the media almost makes it seem like
depression is a prerequisite to success
but there are obviously plenty of
brilliant people who didn't suffer from
mental illness or were otherwise normal
they just aren't as sensational to write
listicles about as say a guy who fell in
love with the pigeon so is it true does
being a genius or even just pretty smart
make you destined for misery well maybe
one study asked 3700 Mensa members or
people who were so proud of their IQ
scores that they joined an organization
to brag about it if they were currently
dealing with mental illness more than a
third said they were depressed to put
that in context that's five times the
national average if you rounded up a
hundred Mensa members and a hundred
regular people about six to seven of
those regular people would probably be
depressed well more than 30 of the Mensa
members would be a few caveats the Mensa
members were asked to self-report on
their own well-being hear of those who
reported feeling depressed roughly 10
percent didn't have a doctor telling
them they actually had depression as
anyone who spends way too much time
googling symptoms knows the art of self
diagnosis is far from perfect plus are
these medicines representative of all
smart people probably not still there
might be a biological basis for why
highly intelligent people are prone to
depression her Pinsky who ran the Mensa
study asserted the people with IQs of
130 plus have hyper
brains that is they can comprehend the
world's problems uncertainties and
possibilities more easily than people
with non hyper brains the whole hyper
brain idea was based on the work of
psychiatrist dr. Kazimierz Dobrowski who
noticed his exceptionally smart patients
had a tendency to overly contemplate
everything especially the bad stuff at
times they also seem to experience
deeper depression compared to the
intellectually average these traits were
part of a group of characteristics that
he called overexcite ability he didn't
see it as a bad thing instead he thought
it was predictive of the potential for
being able to achieve the most ideal
version of oneself in 1972 he wrote one
who manifests several forms of
overexcite ability sees reality in a
different stronger and more excitable
manner Dobrowski said that overexcite
abilities come in five flavors excessive
energy or nervousness deep appreciation
for things like art or music being
extremely curious or having an active
mind having a vivid imagination and
finally extreme and complex emotional
experiences rick is a textbook example
of all of these things he's still slang
aliens on the Reg at 70 years old
freestyles award-winning tracks on a
whim you gotta use with me you gotta get
okay maybe that's not appreciation but
still can be just a tiny bit over
analytical you're both pieces is capable
of thinking up and inventing entire
worlds and has seriously complicated
feelings for his family while it hasn't
been tested scientifically some
psychologists believe that people who
think this way are more prone to what's
called existential depression it's
exactly what it sounds like fillings of
hopelessness that come from wondering
whether life is ultimately meaningless
dr. James Webb a psychologist who
studies gifted kids notes that while
existential depression can happen to
anybody following a crisis it's more
likely to happen spontaneously to people
whose intelligence is above average
Rick never comes out and says he's
crushed beneath the weight of a futile
existence but he certainly comes close
you know smart people get a chance to
climb on top take reality for a ride but
it'll never stop trying to throw you and
eventually it will there's no other way
off on top of that he's bored senseless
virtually nothing in our own mundane
world impresses him but his intellectual
prowess and imagination enable him to
find temporary reprieve from boredom by
way of his portal gun Aidid adventures
oh and alcohol contrast this with Jerry
Jerry possesses none of the traits
psychologists associated with hyper
brain unless you count getting super
stoked about rare coins there's little
r2d2 s where the George Washington
should be the mobile games or the
Titanic so does that mean he's
inherently happier but before we get
there real-life Helen here for a second
I want to take a minute to talk about
this video sponsor better help which is
an online counseling service for those
of you who saw our Bo Burnham video you
know Jared gave him a whirl and he dug
it knowing I like many people might be
able to benefit from talking to someone
on a regular basis he suggested I give
him a try too so I did stick around to
the end of the video to hear more about
my experience in the meantime go to
better help calm slash wisecrack one to
learn more now back to Jerry okay so
does jerry's jerry 'no smee he's happier
nope but it's complicated while some
studies may suggest that being smart
makes you more likely to be depressed
others suggest that intelligence gives
you the ability to unlock a lot of
amazing doors in life that will make you
healthier and sometimes happier
specifically money as pretty much all of
the studies on IQ and depression point
being smart is associated with greater
wealth and therefore better health
though sometimes it gets hard to
distinguish what causes what among the
zillions of criticisms of IQ tests is
that kids who come from well-off
families are more likely to be tested in
the first place that being said the
relationship between achievement money
and intelligence throws a wrench in the
idea the genius equals misery in some
studies having a higher IQ has actually
been associated with greater happiness
one study looked at more than 6800
people and found that IQ was positively
correlated with well self-reported
happiness genius has long been
associated with eccentricity and few
geniuses fictional or otherwise can live
up to the eccentricity of Rick Sanchez
it's safe to say rick has a tendency to
overwhelm people with his intensity some
researchers have said this is a hallmark
of people with high IQs what these
eccentricities may freak out the normal
minded people around them leaving our
geniuses socially isolated trying to
roll with the normies requires
minimizing that intensity which can lead
to a so-called crisis of self where
conformity makes people feel lost and
confused about who they really are one
could argue that Rick's in a perpetual
crisis of self on earth he's forever an
oddball and while that doesn't seem to
concern him too much it does mean he has
to compromise his nature for the sake of
his relationship with his family
like when he finally shows up to therapy
I have no doubt that you would be bored
senseless by therapy the same way I'm
bored when I brush my teeth and wipe my
ass because the thing about repairing
maintaining and cleaning is it's not an
adventure yet just because Jerry isn't
an eccentric genius doesn't mean he
doesn't have his own problems fitting in
he's seriously lacking in social skills
Jerry stop networking room space
survival skills look I'm not proud to
share this but the truth is I just kept
crawling and it kept working or skills
of any kind really he's most successful
in a career where he doesn't even know
what he does I tell you the Galactic
Federation taking over earth best thing
that's ever happened to his family
I just got my six promotion this week
and I still don't know what I do and is
otherwise so utterly incompetent that he
has to beg his kids for money Oh God dad
please don't I just need a few hundred
dollars to get through the month I have
some interviews coming up
that's gonna come through I can feel it
ultimately as Rick points out after the
world leader Li Fiasco the only reason
Jerry's able to get by is because
everyone feels sorry for him you act
like prey but you're a predator you use
pity to lure in your victims how you
survive
Rick gets his way by intimidating people
while Jerry relies on their mercy so
let's recap some research suggests that
the hyper brains of highly intelligent
people make them more prone to
depression mainly because they see the
world in a different way and are more
intense than your average homo sapien
which is kind of a turn-off to the
average joes but at the same time the
fact that they can leverage their smarts
for high-paying jobs that enable them to
avoid the stresses of poverty and afford
better healthcare means that as a group
they're more likely to be happier
overall to our original question is it
really better to know the worst and be
unhappy than to be happy in a fool's
paradise to be a Rick rather than a
Jerry research says well that's a
subjective ask question and frankly
psychology doesn't have a concrete
answer thank psychology I went to school
for you but limited evidence that is out
there suggest that while you may be less
likely to suffer from existential
depression as a Jerry you're more likely
to live a better life overall as a Rick
but which would you rather be wisecrack
drop us a line in the comments below and
thanks for watching
alright guys thanks for sticking around
so this video was sponsored by the
online counseling service better help
we've talked about them before and they
wound up sponsoring this video to better
help takes an inventory of what you're
looking for in therapy and then they
match you with a licensed counselor
within 24 hours I'm a full time
journalist who freelances for companies
like wisecrack on the side so it's
really hard for me to commit to a set
time for therapy every week my better
help therapist was extremely patient and
totally understood my crazy schedule
plus she was really accessible and
responsive one of the best parts about
it is that you don't have to talk to
your therapist over videoconferencing if
you don't want to or if you just don't
have time you can reach out to them over
the phone or through messaging or
through live chat and you can get a hold
room while you're in your garage or your
bed or just wherever and it's all
completely confidential we all know we
should make mental health priority but
getting over the stigma or just finding
the time can be super challenging so if
you've been thinking about talking to a
therapist consider checking out better
help at better helped calm slash
wisecrack 1 or click the link in the
description below thanks so much for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]